on ne bouge pas pendant le single
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle bien
ça c'est fait alterview première fois
premier souvenir
la première fois à tout de suite bah oui
c'est un grand truc dont on parle de
sexe j'y pense mais ça aurait pu être
sympa moi c'est avant 13 ans vous avez
commencé tard en plus 15 ans et demi
c'est bien ça je dois dire premier choc
de votre vie c'est pas obligatoire du
sexe anal ya pas longtemps ce qu'avec un
membre de ma famille
je voulais
venus est valable je vais me gêner
premier mensonge il n'a pas duré
longtemps c'est une tromperie le trompe
et vague
oui non mais ça a duré deux jours que
j'ai joué on est déçus il a fait avant
moi
c'est ça l'esprit qui sont durs en tête
premier péché de gourmandise secret
première main mon papa ouais premier
coup de foudre
greg grèce aux grecs quand même premier
baiser sans la langue sans la langue
c'était tard ah bon j'ai commencé avec
la langue
j'ai déjà mon mac comme à côté attend
des jeux c'était en quatrième xavier 4e
n'ont pas quel âge
non
et alors maintenant une horrible et avec
la langue avec la langue avec la langue
si tu sais pas non plus la première fois
alors danse avec greg
oui à l'âge de 16 ans oui je dis oui
comme ça parce qu'il ya eu un effet avec
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'était un très
mauvais souvenir
ah bon c'est pas bien passé non ma
première vraie foi voilà les premières
fois avec une fille c'était pour la
thune faire c'était pour l'anniversaire
de greg je comprends pas comment on
pourrait se voir plus souvent préparé un
petit cadeau
il regarde exactement c'est une fille
dont j'avais envie et finalement ça
c'est pas prévu on était dans une soirée
tout ça et on est rentrés tous les trois
voies la holding suisse on n'a pas vu la
grille il ya un bravo et félicitations à
ces situations très béni des dieux
vous rentrez jamais avec un copain
vainqueur avec le pain oui il pourrait
avoir envie de rentrer avec un copain
greg aussi fort et que ce soit moi qui
en ai envie ah bon c'est vous qui
décidez oui mais je pense que c'est
normal dans un couple que ce soit la fin
de la femme a plus besoin de choses pour
le sexe comme un homme c'est assez
facile et pas mal c'est bien enfin
souvent une fille a plus besoin d'eux
des choses pour donc première fois à
troyes vous venez de le dire première
fois 4 on va tout dire c'était y'a pas
longtemps et a5 jamais ah bon vous êtes
tout à apprendre encore premières scènes
de ménage quand même j'espère que c'est
allende dans un beau coup de pub à bon
oui on discute beaucoup hein on aime
bien vous aimez bien pour la
réconciliation merci bien sûr les
premiers amours c'est qui votre vrai
premier à mon tour pareil non bah oui
deux nouveautés
désigne l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux